democrats tonight they're not even
trying to hide their dangerous open
borders agenda
as congresswoman the real speaker of the
house uh
ocasio-cortez and dozens of other house
democrats they are coming out against
the deportation of illegal immigrant
gang members
you heard me right claiming in a new
letter that an ice enforcement memo
quote invites
racial profiling because the agency is
making
it a removal priority to deport those
who have been convicted
of actively or intentionally
participating in gang activity
that would sound like common sense
seriously democrats now coming out in
defense of violent criminals
instead of supporting law and order and
the safety and security
of the american people how exactly would
stopping deportations of violent gang
members
help public safety protect the most
vulnerable
what will people do remember border
security it's about
safety border security is about national
security
and we face a whole host of threats when
our borders
aren't secure our sovereignty and our
laws are not respected
for example we are learning that house
minority leader kevin mccarthy has been
briefed
on a classified memo about terror
suspects
caught at the u.s mexico border last
year
told fox news he's quote even more
concerned for america's security than he
ever was before
what's it going to take for democrats to
take the border crisis seriously
and what will it take for democrats to
be honest with the american people
instead of substituting political
theater for real
solutions on nearly every issue
immigration
reckless spending amplifying lies about
voting laws playing the race card and so
much more
all with the approval of woke corporate
america
thankfully conservatives they are
fighting back one group taking on
these far left corporations with ads
like this take a look
american airlines rated the worst losing
the most bags
shrinking legroom during covid american
requires passengers to show id
to fly but attacks texas's popular voter
id
law why is ceo doug parker trying to
appease the radical left
at joe's state of delaware he
represented them 5
820 years they have voter id yeah
of course don't expect any serious or
critical coverage from the mob and the
media
on any of this as we're now learning
tonight they
might be scared of ending up on kamala
harris's
bad list a new report in the atlantic
uncovering that harris actually keeps
tabs on journalists
who she suspects may not quote
understand her or appreciate her life
experience
wonder where i end up on the list wow
can you imagine if donald trump did that
here with reaction
south carolina uh senator lindsey graham
senator iraq
your reaction first of all to all of
that
well there's a lot to unpack let's start
with the border we're inviting a
terrorist attack
on our country on the 20th anniversary
of 9 11
by losing control of the border how hard
is it for a terrorist organization to
figure out
that you can put terrorists in this flow
of illegal immigrants
crossing our border we're equivocating
on
standing with israel i will be in
charleston south carolina tomorrow night
rallying christians and the israeli
community and
freedom-loving south carolinians to
stand with israel
two things i'm certain of hamas would
kill
every israeli if they could the only
reason they're not
is because israel can defend itself and
israel could kill
tens of thousands of palestinians if
they wanted to
they don't they want to live in peace
they want to live in security
so to my democratic colleagues who are
pushing israel to stop
attacking hamas degrading hamas
you're wrong israel if you're listening
do what you need to do to protect
yourself
this war needs to continue you continue
it
we have your back don't stop until
you get every hamas terrorist you can
and yes they take great they take great
concern
in protecting innocent life but hamas
they fire their missiles from
oh schools and hospitals and uh
they if anyone dies innocent people
collateral damage as we say
that would be on them they're the ones
firing thousands of rockets into israel
let me go back to the border 90 percent
of our heroin
90 percent of fentanyl in this country
the opioid crisis killing 300 plus
americans a week
it crosses that border now we're going
to have people on the left defending
gang members
from deportation i think between that
and and california new york and new
jersey giving checks to illegal
immigrants i think i've about heard it
all
we've done everything but take an ad out
in the paper come to america we're
stopping deportations
they're basically put eyesight of
business joe biden's overwhelmed by the
job of being president
the left has lost its mind there's more
fentanyl across the border
this time in 2021 and all of 2020
israel is under the gun 3 500 rockets
where is it coming from
iran to the biden administration you
would be insane
to start negotiating with iran as long
as they're
still the largest state sponsor of
terrorism so i am very worried about our
national security i'm very worried about
our border here at home 2022 is going to
be a hell of an election
if you're a conservative person and you
don't vote in 2022
you have nobody to blame but yourself i
miss donald trump
none of this would happen if president
trump would be impris was president
today
i hope he's considering running let's
start a draft trump movement
he's the one guy i think can go to the
american people and say
let me finish what i started what i did
worked
i like focus on the agenda his agenda
work conservatism works anytime those
policies are implemented
it works and i think putin kim jong-un
the muellers in iran and chi in china
they feared trump they don't fear this
guy lindsay
you got it my friend they they're
cleaning our clock and when trump was on
was president united states there was a
different attitude the world had toward
the united states
and i miss that attitude we're weaker
today than we've been since jimmy carter
lindsey graham thank you hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else